enfin pur de la côte est jeune c'est
raté il me semblait avoir entendu
chanter reuters ont fui via c'est moi
reste que vous êtes les faits sont là
johnny qu'est-ce que peut fabriquer de
l'essence et sur le quai désolé pas la
la la bonté près mon grand ja je suis
prêt de chez près chaque habitant de
cette ville a une chance de devenir une
star grâce à notre concours de chant
vous allez être ébouriffés par le pegi
[Musique]
ça va très bien merci
fo
si vous voulez devenir des stars et
gagner 100 mille dollars vous allez
devoir travailler plus dur que vous ne
l'avez jamais fait toute votre vie
oui c'était très mauvais ou et joly eelv
est pas là oui c'était une répétition
papa je veux pas faire partie de pong ce
que je veux c'est être chanteur comment
j'ai fait pour avoir un fils comme toi
tu es limité litres chez toi et
comprendra que bulgari veuille ou non je
suis là qu'est ce qui se passe ici
il faut jamais laisser la peur nous
empêcher de faire ce qu'on aime c'est ce
qu'il ya bien quand on a touché le fond
c'est qu'il ne reste plus qu'une issue
on doit
et
c'est le monde fiston
elle est hyper nu celle là ouais non
c'est clair je peux pas bouger
[Musique]
allez chante
à
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en train de
répéter cette fois c'est moi ils m'ont
carrément accusé d'être égocentrique
je sais même pas ce que ça veut dire